so surely are you backing down off the
fight are you interested where is your
head at now that you see Chris face to
face and he's calling you out and saying
he wants to fight with you I think you'd
be better off going to some other offers
buddy I appreciate you well there it is
Shu Li is backing off on Chris's fight
Howard we're just talking in here and
there's a guy in here who really has no
beef with bagel boss guy but we'd love
to make 10 grand and that's my Matt he
wants a boxing he doesn't really want a
box with Nicolas I'd like to make 10
grand I'd fight him come in here I think
you could beat up my med he's skinny you
might be angry at him because he's kind
of handful he gets laid a lot does it
yeah here are you crazy what this guy
will kill me look at his size I'm
appalled he's too big and he's talking I
think you could take him no I don't that
was quicker than a Tyson fight meanwhile
I don't see anyone willing to step up
and fight Julie makes the most sense man
he's is a great guy but Benji said he
wants a tickle bagel boss up for that
Benji get in here tell me what that's
all smell your [ __ ] you know I get
tickled pinche what's up with that why
don't we get someone closer to my hide I
have a contract I guess Julie's kind of
the perfect guy because he's your hi oh
he's not I got a 9 year old daughter you
want me to go get her you see that's the
kind of [ __ ] you gotta put up with it's
coming from a [ __ ] guy that's 2
inches taller than oh listen four-eyes
you know you could fight well JD he's
your height he's a little bit taller
than you but he's in terrible shape
why don't you get your ass in the ring a
little
[Laughter]
you're a man of small stature but no one
wants to fight you beat me you can peg
me in the ass